his administration is right now
suing in court right now to invalidate
the law
go tell a mother or father whose son or
daughter has cancer and they can't get
insurance
because they no longer have the
protection that that
is hysterical shame hhs
what is going on here we're talking
about lives
well let's bring in health and human
services secretary alex azar to talk
about the president's health care policy
mr secretary thanks for the time
good to be with you brett thanks for
having me you just heard senator schumer
uh speaker pelosi just moments ago
speaker pelosi put out a statement
saying that
that the president's executive order is
bogus it's not worth the paper it's
signed on and it's an
insult to every family relying on this
pre-existing condition health care what
do you say to that
well first off the president today
announced a bold
plan to deliver better care more choice
and lower cost for the american people
and let's talk about pre-existing
conditions the president and his
executive order today said it's the
policy of the united states to ensure
that people with pre-existing conditions
are protected
whether under existing law or if there's
any replacement ever passed but let's be
clear about the status quo brett
right now under this glorified obamacare
that many want to talk about that they
say protects people with pre-existing
conditions
a family of two age 55 in missouri
making seventy thousand dollars a year
will spend thirty thousand dollars a
year on premiums and twelve
thousand dollars in deductible i'm sorry
that's not the protection against
pre-existing conditions that's not
affordable health care that doesn't
solve their problem
president trump wants to work with
congress to solve their problems in a
real way
so when you say work with congress a gop
plan has been tough to really pin down
uh
since the effort to kind of dismantle
and and throw away obamacare failed and
now it's obviously in the courts
there really hasn't been one gop plan
has there
well right now given that the democrats
control the house there's certain
limited degrees of freedom in terms of
what one realistically can achieve by
legislation so what the president's done
over the last
three and a half years has
revolutionized health care in the united
states to deliver better care more
choice
and lower cost he has done more in three
and a half years
to help all 331 million americans health
care
than any president in modern history
it's more than obamacare obamacare
is about 20 25 million people on
individual insurance and in
the medicaid expansion he's bringing
transparency across the system
your ownership of your own electronic
records he's changing health care in a
fundamental way that benefits every
american not just a sliver in obamacare
so if uh as expected the president gets
his supreme court nominee
through the senate confirmation process
if
as expected then that justice sits on
the court and rules
on this obamacare case what does the
administration tell
the people out there who are concerned
that they won't have obamacare anymore
as they head into the dangers of covid
and flu season and everything else
well i'll tell you what the president
has said which is first and foremost
he's going to make sure people with
pre-existing conditions are protected
and he's going to replace it he'll work
with congress as constituted at the time
if such a thing happens
with congress at that time to deliver
better health care for people
obamacare didn't deliver for them we can
deliver really good
quality health care for people better
choice actually you know
instead of the false promises that
obamacare just uh
basically uh failed to deliver on of
keep your doctor keep your insurance
plan all those lies that we're told
actually deliver lower cost more choice
better care
you know one of the things we did today
the president did today for the first
time in history
he has now allowed as of today the
pathways for importation of lower-cost
drugs from other countries
no president's ever done that before
every democrat has always said when
they've been president oh i'm going to
do that and they failed to do it
today president trump did that opening
pathways for states to import for
individuals to import
and for low-cost insulin to be
re-imported into the united states where
it is made
i want to ask you one last question
about uh the vaccine
and the process the fda uh the
the fda the head of the fda speaking out
about that dr han
about the the process and the president
weighing in about how fast it's going to
take
take a listen science will guide our
decisions
fda will not permit any pressure from
anyone
to change that i will fight for science
mr chairman i will fight for the
integrity of the agency
and i will put the interests of the
american people before anything else
i don't see any reason why it should be
delayed further because
if they delete delay in a week or two
weeks or three weeks
you know that's a lot of lives you're
talking about
if the fda says we have to slow this
down
is the administration okay with that
if science and data and the legal
constructs say slow down then we slow
down
but here's what we're doing we're making
historic progress with great speed
thanks to operation warp speed we've
taken the financial risk away from the
process
for the drug companies and as a result
we now have four vaccines and phase
three clinical trials we have two public
company
ceos for pfizer and modernist saying we
could see clinical trial results by the
end of october we literally are making
millions of doses of drugs as we speak
at commercial
size scale so that we can have 100
million doses
of fda gold standard vaccine by the end
of the year
and we will not compromise on safety and
efficacy standards there are many
independent checks breath that are built
into this system an
independent data and safety monitoring
board decide if we even see data
according to pre-specified endpoints
a drug company will then have to review
it and consider the data according to
their own ethical standards before even
submitting an application
and then the fda will call the balls and
strikes by career officials
according to the safety and efficacy
standards that they have published
publicly
and they're going to use an independent
advisory committee to guide this the
american people should be reassured
any vaccine that is approved by the fda
is going to be safe and effective
according to the officials and standards
of the food and drug administration
mr secretary we appreciate your time i'd
love to have you back